INDIVIDUALS AND THE PRESIDENT
HAS INCENTIVIZED THIS.
>> Dana: LET’S BRING IN FORMER
ACTING ICE DIRECTOR TOM HOMAN.
LET’S ASK YOU ABOUT THE
BREAKING NEWS.
PERSONNEL, POLICY.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
FINALLY ANNOUNCING WHO THEY
WOULD LIKE TO NOMINATE TO RUN
CUSTOMS AND BORDER PROTECTION,
A POLICE CHIEF IN TUCSON,
ARIZONA.
I DON’T KNOW IF YOU’RE FAMILIAR
WITH THAT.
IF YOU ARE GET YOUR THOUGHTS
AND FILLING THIS POSITION.
>> I’M NOT FAMILIAR WITH HIM
BUT IF HE IS IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
IT’S PROBABLY A GOOD THING.
IF TUCSON IS STILL A SANCTUARY
AND HE SUPPORTS THAT I HAVE A
HUGE PROBLEM WITH IT.
I WOULD HAVE TO RESEARCH HIM
MORE TO FIND OUT WHERE HE
STANDS ON IMMIGRATION.
YOU CAN’T RUN CBP AND BELIEVE
IN SANCTUARY CITIES.
>> Dana: GOVERNOR ABBOTT SAID
35,000 MIGRANT CHILDREN IN
FEDERAL CUSTODY BY JUNE IS WHAT
HE SAID.
>> AND THERE IS A REPORT IN THE
"NEW YORK TIMES," GOVERNOR,
THAT THE GOVERNMENT NOW
PROJECTS MORE THAN 35,000
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS IN FEDERAL
CUSTODY BY JUNE.
ONE, COULD IT GET THAT BAD?
AND TWO, WHAT’S THE BIGGEST
SINGLE THING THAT PRESIDENT
BIDEN COULD DO TO STOP THE
SURGE?
>> FIRST CHRIS I WILL TELL YOU
THAT CANDIDLY I EXPECT THAT
NUMBER TO BE FAR HIGHER.
>> Dana: HE EXPECTS THE NUMBER
TO BE HIGHER.
LET ME PUT THE NUMBERS ON THE
SCREEN FOR YOU.
THE NUMBER OF UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS ENCOUNTERED IN JANUARY
WAS 5,852.
THESE ARE ALL KIDS UNDER THE
AGE OF 18.
IN MARCH UP TO 18,890.
IF YOU DO THE MATH PERHAPS
GOVERNOR ABBOTT IS CORRECT IT
WOULD BE MORE THAN 35,000?
>> I THINK IT WILL BE HIGHER.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
DOING, THEY’RE SPENDING
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS SETTING UP
MORE WELCOME CENTERS SO THEY
CAN MOVE THESE MIGRANTS THROUGH
THE PROCESS QUICKER BECAUSE IF
THEY CAN PREVENT OVERCROWDING
THEN THEY WILL SAY IT’S NOT A
CRISIS.
EVEN THOUGH THOUSANDS ARE
COMING EVERY DAY AND BEING
RELEASED THERE IS NOT A CRISIS
ACCORDING TO THEM.
THEM OWE GET GOOD AT RELEASING
PEOPLE.
THE NUMBERS WILL CLIMB
EXTRAORDINARY HIGH RATES BUT
THEY’LL HAVE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN FACILITIES THEY’RE
BUILDING TO GET THEM THROUGH
THE PROCESS MORE EFFICIENTLY.
WHY AREN’T THEY STOPPING IT?
SPEND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
TAXPAYER MONEY TO RELEASE THESE
PEOPLE QUICKLY.
GET BACK TO CATCH AND RELEASE.
HOW ABOUT ACTUALLY ENFORCING
THE LAW?
IT WOULD COST A LOT LESS.
ENFORCING THE LAW IS WHAT THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION DROPPED
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION 70%.
REINSTATE THE REMAIN IN MEXICO
PROGRAM.
LET THE BORDER AGENTS SECURE
THE BORDER A AND LET ICE DO
THEIR JOB AND ENFORCE
IMMIGRATION LAWS IN THE
INTERIOR.
PEOPLE COMING ACROSS THAT
BORDER KNOW THEY’LL BE RELEASED
AND NEVER BE REMOVED.
ICE CAN’T REMOVE THEM.
IT HAS BEEN DECAPITATED.
STILL THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
STARTS TAKING LAW ENFORCEMENT
SERIOUS IT’S NOT GOING TO STOP.
>> Dana: LISTEN THE TYLER
MORAN, A SPECIAL ASSISTANT TO
PRESIDENT BIDEN ON IMMIGRATION
AND DOMESTIC POLICY COUNCIL.
I’LL GET YOUR TAKE.
WATCH.
>> THE BORDERS AREN’T OPEN BUT
WE’RE ALSO FOLLOWING THE LAW.
THE LAW SAYS WHEN THESE PEOPLE
COME TO OUR BORDER AND THEY ASK
FOR PROTECTION THAT WE CAN
PROCESS THEM.
NOT EVERYBODY WILL QUALIFY AND
NOT EVERYBODY IS GOING TO STAY.
BUT WE’RE NOT A COUNTRY THAT
WILL TURN KIDS BACK INTO THE
DESERT BY THEMSELVES.
>> Dana: QUICK COMMENT FROM YOU
ON THAT, TOM.
SEEMINGLY THEY AREN’T CHANGING
ANYTHING.
>> FIRST OF ALL THEY AREN’T
ENFORCING ANY LAWS.
SHE IS WRONG.
IF THESE PEOPLE ARE CLAIMING
ASYLUM THEY’RE NOT CONDUCTING
ASYLUM INTERVIEWS.
THEY PROCESS AND RELEASE THEM.
NO INTERVIEWS ARE BEING
CONDUCTED.
SHE DOESN’T KNOW WHAT SHE IS
TALKING ABOUT.
I’M TIRED OF THEM SAYING MEN
AND WOMEN OF THE BORDER PATROL
SEND PEOPLE BACK TO THE DESERT
TO DIE.
THEY ARE BEING TREATED HUMANELY
BY BORDER CONTROL AGENT.
THE ONLY HUMANITY ON THE
SOUTHERN BORDER ARE THE MEN AND
WOMEN WEARING GREEN THE WAY
THEY TREAT CHILDREN AND WOMEN.
NOBODY IS SENDING PEOPLE BACK
TO THE DESERT TO DIE.
UNLIKE WHAT PRESIDENT BIDEN
SAID DURING HIS SPAOEFRP NO ONE
IS WATCHING CHILDREN STARVE TO
DEATH.
>> Dana: LAST QUESTION TO YOU.
THERE IS A REPORT THE WHITE
HOUSE IS CONSIDERING THE
POSSIBILITY OF SENDING DIRECT
PAYMENTS TO PEOPLE IN CENTRAL
AMERICA TO TRY TO GET THEM NOT
TO COME.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> ARE WE HELD HOSTAGE NOW?
WE HAVE TO PAY PEOPLE NOT TO
VIOLATE OUR LAW?
YOU WILL SEE THE MIGRANT
NUMBERS GET HIGHER THAN THEY
ARE NOW.
YOU GIVE THEM MONEY SO THEY CAN
PAY A SMUGGLER TO GET THEM HERE.
IT IS RIDICULOUS.
YOU DON’T HAVE TO SPEND ALL
THIS MONEY.
LET BORDER PATROL AND ICE
ENFORCE THE LAW.
LET BORDER PATROL SECURE THE
BORDER.
THEY DID IT UNDER THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND THEY CAN DO
IT AGAIN.
YOU SEND MONEY TO CENTRAL
AMERICANS, MORE PEOPLE SMUGGLED
TO THE UNITED STATES.
THEY’LL TURN THE MONEY OVER TO
SMUGGLERS.
>> Dana: ALWAYS GOOD TO BE WITH
YOU.
I’M SURE WE’LL SEE YOU AGAIN